hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are wearing white
today looks like I got a bald spot on
camera here looks like I have very large
forehead topper war tear video requests
comes from the channel mind boggler the
request comes from a man named Jason
Dolan who's actually just a really close
friend of ours and we even watched the
movie us together and we take his money
yeah easily or else you're not our
friend anymore Jason I tell everyone at
patreon feel free to lower your pledge
if it causes you financial troubles but
Jason that rule does not apply to your
whole friendship is based off that very
conditional kind of friendship 10
scientifically impossible places that
actually exist because it's very in tune
with the channel thank you Jason for
requesting this this is the kind of
thing we've always wanted to branch out
and talk about or called the real
rejects because we don't want to talk
about films or shows I'm gonna talk
about what's real when I was socket if
it could be impossible voices get into
this ooh
so many different wonders like the Grand
Canyon and Victoria Falls are certainly
big and anyone who sees them will surely
be impressed
oh yeah
[Laughter]
not just because they're beautiful but
because they seem to follow scientific
laws that don't exist anywhere else on
earth number 10
Devil's camp what if Nora's natural
mysteries go the devil's kettle in
Minnesota is one of the most intriguing
the rivers waters to the Lake Superior
and the other split well we have no clue
where it goes
aliens a parallel universe programming
some Mayan trick your guess is as good
as mom or just lead somewhere else
scientific mystery okay almost do the
push back lights appear in the sky they
are of bright colors and disappear I
mean to appear the next day during the
night this has been going on for four
decades at least scientists are
perplexed by this mystery there are
theories though but none seems to be
good enough
since at least the early 1930s people
have spotted the lights and hypothesized
what could be causing them one theory
suggests that the lake is radioactive
the radon writes dust particles and upon
elevations in decays and it produces
lights that's the most sense to me man
is full of sulfuric acid sulfur reacts
to the water and produces what
scientists call sparks hundreds of tests
have been performed to pinpoint the
exact cause but to no avail number eight
kid with a laser pointer in southeastern
Romania there is a cave that was locked
away from the slightest ray of light for
5.5 million years and that has a
completely different atmosphere from the
earth the Cape was discovered by workers
looking to set up a power plant they
tested the ground to see if it was a
safe place to build and cracked open a
pathway that leads into one of the
strangest places on earth
if you descend through the narrow shaft
and passed a series of tunnels you enter
a chamber with a lake of sulfuric water
stinking rotten eggs the air there is
toxic sulphide and contaminated with 100
times the surfaces level of carbon
dioxide well this is just part though is
that a whole ecosystem has survived in
sight
researchers have found their new species
inside the cave oh don't exist anywhere
Wow
adapted to survive in a sulfuric
atmosphere living by feeding off a foam
on top of the stones when's the movie
cover set late Carter
the Soviet Union had many nuclear
facilities markets so they built planned
and unsafe inside one such factory there
is a link though Lakes water has more
active material than anywhere else on
earth Lake Carson is so radioactive that
you will still have in an hour
if you stand near it so stand me
register Oh their nuclear practices have
caused a few problems with the lake in
the past in 1957 an explosion blew the
Factory apart and a radioactive
particles spread more than 23,000
kilometers
Wow although Adams been covered with
concrete to keep these disasters from
happening still the entire place is
eerily unstable and massively
radioactive damn it's like Sasha of
Kasasa
in the countryside of pietà there is an
unusual supplement there is a cherry
tree there that looks in most respects
just like any other healthy cherry tree
except that it happens to be growing
directly on top of a mulberry tree what
President parasitic trees have grown out
of others before but normally they are
small stunted things that live short
lives before falling off the Doubletree
of couse ORSA though consists of two
fully formed healthy trees each
spreading its branches five meters
across no one knows how it happened the
locals believe that a bird may have
dropped a cherry seed on top of the ball
bearing tree the seed grew roots hellboy
letting it survive and grow into a thing
a bird might have dropped share seed him
the top of a tree in this creation it is
as real as it gets
what
[Laughter]
identity Thank You Asian topless save
ever closer to solving the problem one
theory suggests that the residents are
facing some kind of radiation poisoning
since the area is near a uranium mine
however there are flaws in that theory
all the blood tests and other monitoring
has turned up zero evidence secondly
there is a town which is closer to the
mind than Kawachi and they have reported
no such epidemic great place to catch up
on some sleep no choice there are fields
of grass with circles carved in that at
regular intervals the circles are almost
perfectly created and can range from 10
to 65 feet in diameter and by the way if
you are thinking of the movie the signs
you are not alone it's actually called
fine scientists are even sure of the
more basic questions such as why are
there circles why not any random shape
nothing grows in these circle patches
scientists have come up with various
theories and all have been debunked
almost immediately in 2013 norbert
Jergens an environmental scientist said
that termites were the cause of the
circles but in 2015 biologists Walter
shingle tested the hypothesis and
disproved it number three the hum of
Taos a barely audible buzzing sound that
you cannot pinpoint can infuriate you we
have all been there when a distant
lawnmower or our TV starts making a buzz
and unless and until we don't find where
it's coming from
it feels like our brain is eating itself
from the inside now imagine the pain and
vision of residents of Taos in New
Mexico since the early 1990s
large numbers of residents of Taos have
complained
it can be heard for humans for a while
there is a theory though scientists
believe that thank you so much for
watching and if you enjoy the video do
share comment
don't forget to subscribe
Wow Wow so many terrible sci-fi movies
are ready to be made all these ideas oh
yeah man get a boiling River movie get
lightning storms movie all the movies
are all these things create some
creatures come out yeah you mean who
likes go to the boiling River and comes
out yeah it's the mysteries these are
all secretly kaiju right can I do inside
of that cave that was like sealed up for
many many years there's a kaiju making
these lights in the sky it's all
explainable via Japanese monster movies
I wonder who these scientists are they
commit themselves to figuring out these
things that's the kind of science I
would want to study if I was assigned to
I would want to find the most
unexplainable things on earth and just
be like I'm gonna take a crack at this
because if I'm gonna sit I mean how cool
is that gonna I figure out what's inside
this weird pant what do they call it
it's like panhandle thing of the reverse
yeah with the two split rivers why'd I
just send the drone in there like that's
one piece of information I would have
liked from this videos it seems like you
could just send like a camera with some
kind of tracking device down there see
what's there and also geo-located
do they need to find out
I don't know some of these I'm like who
do we really need to know do we need
dedicate ourselves to finding especially
the river one don't go down the river
what if it just seeps out on the other
side of the barrier between you what if
it just goes into this basin and then
out the other side somewhere like like
in mini goes the one with the with the
cherry tree growing on top of what was
the other mulberry tree yeah dedicating
their life to try to figure out what's
going on with this tree
someone who's got time perhaps got
stationed in a very rural area like some
of these I hear the theories then
they're like good it's been disprove or
we don't know for sure sometimes I'm
just like - sure just let it be it's
what some like weird epidemic where your
trees are performing some type of hybrid
like that [ __ ] trees growing oranges
the kinds of things that make me want to
believe in some kind of really sentient
higher powers just sitting around going
I'm gonna mess with these guys right now
check this out you know a tree yeah all
right I'm gonna put another one just
right on top but god that looks so
stupid but now it's gonna blow their
minds people are gonna lie about me
trying to figure this out for decades to
come now it is a fascinating sight to
see because it is just blatantly one
tree growing out of the top of another
tree the one that really fascinated me
was the sleeping's maybe because I'm
drawn to sleep asleep in city of Kokomo
cheap all the day that's that's bizarre
people just falling asleep like if I go
in here like a narcolepsy epidemic yeah
that's scary I mean all of these would
be fascinating to know the reasoning for
but that's one word especially if I
lived in here near there I'll be like
please tell us what's going on
yeah red must be really cheap there yeah
yeah please please imagine the rent
where the lightning lightning showers
are Oh buddy
they said I think I was like two-thirds
of the year yeah this it was like 260
odd days or something like that
yeah which is insane to me and and that
it should stop for you know a few weeks
just at random like that's exactly like
that's fascinating to me cuz that seems
like true
large-scale chemistry almost it seems
like there's must be the
right combination of factors
contributing to the atmosphere around
that area they're just leading to this
happening but the footage looks like
people live around here what are you
maybe there's Lent is $50 a month I just
go cheap we got lightning storms most of
the year that will pay util it take the
roots are getting struck by lightning
most of the huge this or someplace
radioactive the boiling River that
sounds I mean he paid this the person
who has this channel painted quite a
devastating picture of what happens to
animals who just get curious
yeah that sounds awful and horrifying
I've actually read about this place
before but to like actually see moving
images of it a great way to kill someone
yeah cuz they'd be virtually
unrecognizable laughter right who's toss
them in and they're like boiled I else
right what would happen to their teeth
that's the thing is you'd have to if
their teeth remain intact and their
skeleton remains intact then you might
still be screwed but if you need to get
rid of a body taking to the boiling
River hey I was gonna go down there oh
yeah cuz like I mean you're gonna really
have to pull out some big machinery to
go scourge that Lake I want to go to the
hum city I know it's not been unplugged
yet solve a whole town's problems just
by poking around I'm plugging things how
about to turn the power off in the city
for a day okay see if it's still there
citywide ordinance at 5:00 p.m. on this
day we all unplug all of our belongings
and then plug them back in one at a time
and if the hum comes back we know whose
it is
you know what you do you just take
people who have gone deaf to that
frequency and relocate them all to that
down the holes in the ground oh yeah
these like strange circles must be a
hard place to go if you have that fear
of surveys I just have a hard time
putting myself in the mindset of the
person who if you live there and they
start to form I can understand the like
what is going on here this is scaring me
this is unknown damn it I don't know it
must dedicate my life to science to
figure it out but if you're somebody
like stumbles across this information
you're like I don't know why this why
are you dedicated yourself to this is
kind of silly
let the termite Theory just stand who
cares
man there there are enough people curing
cancer but you could grip bring it round
solving a world mystery you know because
the title ten scientifically applause -
possibly I thought we were gonna see
some like like cultures or lost city of
some yeah yes I'm like that like O'Shea
we went underwater there were buildings
they heard an entire cannibal society
yeah something like that that was what
we were gonna look at early there's a
half of these are things that people
just so yeah but then they're half of
them down like that that's pretty
terrifying lightning city I'd like to go
there I love to just drive through there
yeah let's see how many bolts you can
I'm sure that's the place where you can
figure out how to time travel
what are those oh yeah that's a good
idea right yeah you got to do what Marty
McFly in the Back to the Future
Silvestri music Owen got me damn can get
up to 88 that's all that's all you need
to get to yeah lightning to the rest
well thanks Jason this is a weird video
fascinating though you like to mix it up
don't you buddy
what more can I say in your shout out
dude you're you're Jason Dolan JD I just
text you this morning we're friends
you don't need a shot at this point you
just yeah man let's somebody else bad
one thanks for the camera filming on and
thanks for cutting with me during us it
really made me feel safe was right about
the cinema score I was right about the
cinema score and I know audience I know
people that in you ever will
good luck being a writer Jason [ __ ]
[ __ ] guys you can subscribe to mr.
marble nuts what's this guy's mind
boggler mr. marble man is my mug ler
check out this video give it a like and
we'll see you guys soon peace out